ça les séries j'avais beau symbole c'est
férié
et oui c'est le 8 mai alors pourquoi le
8 mai est férié c'est parti alors non je
vais demander d'abord c'est qu'on a ouai
c'est qu'on n'y a pas kelly c'est vrai
que là au niveau de la culture générale
a grimpé de l'information supplémentaire
pourrait donner une conférence au
volontaire sur quoi dire que normalement
le 8 mai 45 c'est l'armistice
oui paris est en fait ça ça devrait être
le 7 mai 45
je recevrai que normalement on a signé
l'armistice le 7 mai 45 je n'ai pas
staline et comme cet art à la ligne
n'était pas content il avait un tennis
on était dit ou le lendemain on a été re
tout faire resigner pour qu'elle soit
content qu'elle soit tu veux pas me
promener avec mon appart c ou alors le 8
mai 45 je veux des explications claires
doc gynéco à ces mecs on va vous prendre
deux minutes au brushing
[Musique]
du matin jusqu'au rallye à la boîte à
gants oui à la vente mais ration sortie
ce qui de quoi
l'europe l'allemagne a capitulé oui
c'est pas mal non une oreillette
je vais demander à notre meilleur prof
d'histoire ici nos meilleurs pros
d'histoire j'ai demandé à igor et
grichka les chéris pas dites nous
pourquoi lui mais 45 c'est férié un
petit peu d'histoire ne fait jamais de
mal eh bien le 8 mai 45 et nous
apportons tout le corps elle marque
alors dites nous pourquoi
et donc on voit sa 6e non mais
évidemment le mieux mais 45 et est une
transition comment ni historique a su ce
qu'elle marque la date de l'armistice
comme l'armistice avaler l'armistice en
réalité depuis une heure
nous savions évidemment que nous avions
un état de guerre et qui était déclaré
de manière décalée d'ailleurs entre les
deux parties de la france 1 06 milliard
c'est qu'il ya eu une coupure de la
france en deux une partie était engagé
dans le combat et l'autre étaient libres
puis finalement à partir de 42
elle a été entièrement occupée et à
partir de 1945 le yml a été entièrement
libérées et non le rabot voilà merci
grille
alors qu'eric oui bonsoir m c'est
pourquoi on dit de la seconde guerre
mondiale est ce que ça sera pas de
troisième voie qui est jamais de
troisième guerre mondiale omm sont pas
long terme entre les blagues sont à
l'arrêt dont ils n'ont pas dit 12e fois
qu'il atteint la troisième guerre
mondiale dont 10 secondes seront
déterminées c'est comme par exemple la
seconde neuf de maxime gagné on est sûr
qu'elle n'aura pas de troisième manche
mais voilà c'est que c'est un petit peu
voilà c'est un petit peu pareil